le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais le transport scolaire
des élèves et étudiants en situation de
handicap
est une compétence obligatoire du
département
à qui s'adresse-t-il
les élèves ou étudiants porteurs d'un
handicap peuvent être transportés
gratuitement vers les établissements
d'enseignement et ce quel que soit leur
lieu de résidence pour les parents qui
assurent eux mêmes le transport scolaire
de leurs enfants ils peuvent prétendre à
une indemnisation des frais de transport
pour bénéficier de ce dispositif
l'élève ou l'étudiant doit être
titulaire d'une notification de la cdaph
avec un avis favorable pour le transport
scolaire adapté pour avoir plus de
précisions sur cette aide
rendez vous sur le site internet du
département de la réunion au
www.cegedim.fr rubrique transports et
route
vous pouvez également contacter le
service des transports au 02 62 90 04 44
pour l'antenne nord et au 02 62 96 43 41
pour l'antenne sud
les inscriptions sont ouvertes jusqu'au
15 juillet prochain pour l'année
scolaire 2015 2016